俺の家には、一匹の熊がいる
そう、こいつ、所沢だ。
クリッとした目が特徴で、俺が家に帰ってくるといつも、俺を出迎えてくれる。
そんな、ナイスガイだ。
しかしある日、事件は起こってしまった。
ランランランラン♪ただいま！所…
キャアアアアアアアアアアアアア
お…おい…なんだよこれ…！所沢ァァァァ！
いや待て、この顔、この耳、こいつ…
所沢じゃない…
お前、所沢じゃないな！俺の所沢をどこにやった！
ハッ…！
お前まさか…
所沢ァァァ！
おい…所沢
死んでる…
まさか…
まさかあいつが…！
お前がやったのか…？
お前だけはゆるさねぇぞ…！
うわああああああああああ
どこ行きやがった！
うわああ！
なんで宙に浮いてんだ！
なんなんだよお前は！
うわ！
はじめん、ダークネス井上にイジワルしないで
お前どうしちゃったんだよ！
ダークネス井上をいじめないで
やめてくれよ…！ダークネス井上なんて知らねえよ…！
僕はダークネス井上
はじめん、仲良くしようよ。
やめろォ！
仲良くしようよ
うわああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああああ
っていう夢を見ました
所沢がね、一人で「かわいそう」とか「さみしい」とかおもっちゃたんで、
ちょっと彼に、
友達をプレゼントしました
こちらの！「ダークネス井上」さんでーす！
なかなか見ない色なんで、ちょっとびっくりしちゃったんですけども、
これからね、所沢と仲良くしてもらおうと思っております！
ダークネス井上君、よろしくね！
というわけで、今後もね！この所沢新しい彼氏…
え！？
女かお前は？あ、男だ
所沢の友達のダークネス井上君を
今年もよろしくお願いします
じゃーな！
俺んちはどうなっていくんだろう…